so if we know that someone is
susceptible to a certain injury maybe we
can change that maybe we can correct
their DNA so that they're no longer
susceptible to that how far are we
willing to go to improve a player people
have been trying to do gene therapy for
a long time now this is a new way of
doing gene therapy instead of delivering
it through a viruses people have tried
before you can use this new crisper cast
9 system but thinking about what that
might be for athletics we understand the
genetic determinants of human athletic
performance someone somewhere is going
to be thinking of how gene editing could
be used to enhance performance there
will be some they're willing to take the
risk and be kind of guinea pigs and
experiment on themselves and try this
out because the benefit could be so high
I assume that in the same way that drug
testing is performed today maybe in a
future world we might be thinking of
looking for signs of gene editing but
certainly that's a little bit of a scary
thought the excitement around that is
that we could take a particular cell
line that has a disease mutation in it
and edited back to normal of course
people immediately make the jump to if
someone has a disease maybe we can edit
that back to normal and that seems like
something that might be worthwhile
although in general we have to be very
cautious and using the technology
because nothing is a hundred percent
specific and who knows what the other
effects are but perhaps the biggest
question isn't necessarily whether or
not this is the right thing to do but
whether or not it will get done so are
they going to be how fresh and editing
your DNA almost certainly but are people
gonna do it probably
you